they're everywhere apparently algorithms
are in the social media apps we use
every day in search engines even in
dating apps but I'll be honest I've got
absolutely no idea what they actually
are or how they work or who makes them
should we be worried about them can they
think for themselves rather than be
baffled by science I'm gonna go and find
out what on earth is an algorithm where
does every good piece of research start
a search engine so what is an how can I
even spell it oh I think so okay a
process or set of rules to be followed
in calculations or other problem-solving
operations especially by a computer like
a riddle after an hour of searching
about the Internet it all felt a little
overwhelming
so many different definitions without
any clarity in what they actually do
during my search I came across professor
Victoria gnashed from the Oxford
internet Institute
I called to pick her brains we would
tend to explain an algorithm very most
most simply as a set of instructions
right example of a non internet-based
algorithm would be something like a
recipe for example they give you a set
of instructions as to how to put
together several ingredients and get a
product their cake at the other end and
online and algorithm is effectively the
same thing it's a set of instructions
that enable a computer program to put
together different sources of
information and generate a result
speaking to Victoria has helped me
understand what algorithms are well how
can the same thing that helps me bake a
cake also give me the best results from
a search engine no idea I'm taking a
trip to Oxford to visit one of
Victoria's colleagues dr. Bernie Hogan
ready all right easy John nice to see
you we're an ant family so this is our
University's data center it's you know
it's it's pretty big it's really noisy
really you know is it there's a lot of
computation happening here each one of
these belong to different departments
they're doing different kinds of
calculations so there's thousands of
algorithms going on in all of these
massive boxes like and now thousands try
billions billions billions of algorithms
shall we go somewhere a little bit
quieter and talking a little bit more
detail and try and get a better
understanding of how all of this works
sure let's do it it's way to think how
much of our lives go on in non descript
server rooms all over the world well
what exactly are these billions of
algorithms doing so the reason that we
use a list of instructions is because we
have a lot of data and we have to deal
with that data now dare could be
anything data could be a list of towns
in the UK and how I get from one town to
another it could be a number of tweets
which tweet is going to show up at the
top of the list right algorithms
calculate based on a bunch of features
the sort of things that will put
something at the top of the list and
then something at the bottom of the list
so if it's not simple should we be
scared of algorithms well the trick with
algorithms that we perhaps should be a
bit concerned about is what happens in
the black box so he's not light when you
search you something you don't know what
their algorithm is doing because we
can't see it well a classic case of this
is people talk about searching for
prices for flights and depending on
which day you search on you might get a
different flight where you search from
and so this can mean difference of
hundreds of pounds that's an example
where an algorithm is not transparent
and perhaps should be can algorithms
think for themselves well we wouldn't
necessarily think of a computer as
thinking but we know that algorithms can
learn and they can learn from other
algorithms and algorithms can create
their own instructions now but the basis
of it is still the same data goes in
goes through instructions result comes
out I'm beginning to get it but I've
still never actually seen an algorithm I
don't even know what they look like so
I'm heading to one of the UK's leading
coding
to see for myself what goes into making
one so this is cold right yeah so what's
the difference between an algorithm and
cold
coding is algorithms that a computer can
run the instructions for you so we have
to do it in a language which the
computer can actually understand so
we've written this in scratch and it's
really nice to use really intuitive and
you can just drag-and-drop these blocks
and we've got these instructions for the
drone to follow it's going to do a flip
it's gonna do it's time for a challenge
a drone race is ease algorithm versus me
so the course is through the hoop do a
flip come back round land and again so
technically because you're at yours is
programmed by an algorithm you should be
able to do exactly the same thing three
times without a problem that's the plan
okay challenge accepted three I don't
know take off okay yes right up
and then it's gonna fly left you already
ahead but I think mine's more reliable
really oh there we go
[Music]
I'm gonna make the time back in speed
yes you're gonna make it it's gonna need
it look how calm have you done your
three laps I did I did the three laps
yeah so you've won yes so I think the
some of the big benefits of having
algorithms versus kind of humans is that
you don't have the human error the no
offense I think you have yeah you don't
have the human error in the same way the
computer goes through the instructions
and that's all they know how to do the
person writing the code could have
written an error and that's where
problems can arise but it actually the
computer doesn't make mistakes it just
does what it's supposed to doing a
computer might only do what it's
supposed to do but what are the ethical
considerations around algorithms making
so many decisions for us one of the
public concerns is that computers are
taking over the world robots are gonna
take over the world
algorithms are gonna take all of our
jobs is that gonna be the case taking
our jobs it's possible but also do
skilling humans if we become too
dependent on them and too trusting of
them it can dis killers as well but on
the flip side of it there can be hugely
beneficial and useful speeding up
decision makings making whole processes
efficient maybe spotting things that we
might not have spotted ourselves so we
must be frightened of them we just must
use them in the correct manner what have
we learned then algorithms are actually
remarkably simple just like Bernie said
data goes in follows a list of
instructions and a result comes out in
some parts of the world algorithms are
now used in the criminal justice system
in social care in credit checks their
prolific machines making decisions that
directly affect our human life
not just the adverts that you see on the
internet or the people you match on
dating apps the question for society
isn't the algorithm it's who controls
the algorithm and where the data comes
from that goes into them thanks for
watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon